COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYS WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE OR THE SENATE HAD MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR
NORMAL PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE'RE
HOLDING OUT HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH OUR SENATOR SCANNER
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY CENTER
SCANNER. IF YOU HAVE A STAFF
MEMBER PARTICIPATING REMOTE.
WITH YOU PLEASE IDENTIFY THEM
NOW. SENATOR. YES MY STAFF
MEMBERS MARGARET HANDLING GREAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND- CENTER
SKINNER AS REMINDER PLEASE MOVE
YOUR PHONE OR COMPUTER IN THIS
WILL GREATLY OF AID AND
LIMITING ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I
ACID EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THAT
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR- ASKING YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING IN OUR R. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. WHAT'S
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE- YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS OUR
COMMITTEE. TO THE PUBLIC TO
ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WITH THE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS. TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USED AS A WE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICES. FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. NOW FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT%
TOLL FREE NUMBER. AN ACCESS
CODE. IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. IN THE
PARTICIPANT ACCESS CODE. IS.
FIVE SIX FOUR SIX NINE FOUR
SIX. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCE
SYSTEM WORKS. PLEASE REFER TO
THE SENATE AND OR ARE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR THE
DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. PRESS IS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY. FOR THE OPERATOR TO
SIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. AND
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AND AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE ON MUTE AND YOU'LL NOW
BE READY TO ADDRESS OUR
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTED DEVICE
YOU ARE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. AND I
WILL REMAIN TEN TO QUORUM.
DURING THE HEARING AS CUSTOMARY
AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE NEED SERVICE OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
MAY MAY TO STREAMLINE THE
HIRING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS CUSTOMER. THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FORT
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE. OF OUR ONLINE
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENTS SO
THAT ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN
BE HEARD. OKAY. TODAY WE HAVE
TWENTY TWO MANAGERS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA AND I SUGGEST HOLDING
OFF. ON THE CONSENT ITEMS INTO
AFTER AB THREE TO SIX IS
PRESENTED. THIS WILL HELP US
AVOID PUTTING THIS CONSENT
COUNTER ON CALL. NOW BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATIONS ON THE BILLS
AND LET'S ESTABLISH A CORE FORM.
CAN WE HAVE THE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR SPELL YOUR- BILL
HERE BATES HERE PAGE HERE.
ALLEN HERE ALLEN HERE DOLLY
YOUR BILL HERE DOT. HERE HERE
GALGIANI HERE GIRL JENNY HERE
GONZALEZ. MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ
HERE WITH THIS YEAR MORRELL.
HERE WELL HERE ROUGH HERE ROTH
HERE RUBIO. SKINNER. AIR
SKINNER HERE NUMBER THEIR
NUMBER HERE LIKE HEALTHY HERE
LIKE HEALTHCARE. WE HAVE A
QUORUM MISTER CHAIRMAN. THANK
YOU. THE CONSULTANT A QUORUM IS
MENACED OUR SOON OKAY LET'S
HEAR FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR-
THIS IS AB THREE TO SIX AND
CENTER ALLEN UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
PRESENTING A. B. THREE TO SIX
FOR ASSEMBLY MAN MURATSUCHI AND
YOU HAVE AMENDMENTS WHICH YOU
LIKE THE COMMITTEE TO ACCEPT
PLEASE BEGAN CENTER YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR THAT'S CORRECT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AND I I'M I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT
THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUE. ASSUME MEMBER CITY
WAS SENT- PORTIONS OF THE CITY
OF TORRANCE AND SEVEN
CALIFORNIA AND YES WE WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
MOMENTS THAT ARE NOTED ON PAGE
PAGE SIX OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND- PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS IN THIS IS IMPORTANT
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS NEGOTIATED
OVER THE WEEKEND THEY CALLED IT
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED TO ALL OF
YOUR OFFICE IS IF YOU DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE
AMENDMENTS. I'VE BEEN TO YOU
WITH THE PROPOSED I MEAN FOR
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION OF NOW ACTUALLY
SUBMITTED A LETTER IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THIS I JUST WANT
TO TAKE UP TO THINK THAT. IN
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
COMPREHENSIVE WORK THAT THEY
HAVE ENGAGED IN. TO IMPROVE
THIS LEGISLATION OVER THE PAST
MONTH. I REMEMBER SURVEYS SHOW
THAT CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE NOT
OWN AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE ARE
HESITANT TO PURCHASE ONE
BECAUSE OF THE COST. AND
UNFAMILIARITY WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY. CONCERNS WITH THE
RANGE THAT A VEHICLE CAN TRAVEL
BETWEEN CHARGES IN UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT HOW AND WHERE TO CHARGE A
VEHICLE. AND GIVEN THE BROAD
GOALS THAT WE HAVE IS A STATUS
ARE STRONG FEELING THE
CALIFORNIA NEEDS. TO DO MORE TO
REDUCE EACH OF THESE BARRIERS
SO THIS BILL AB THREE TWENTY
SIX BY. THE SUMMER MURATSUCHI
WILL HELP. BY PROVIDING
ELECTRIC VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS
THE AUTHORITY TO OFFER THEIR
EDIE'S TO CUSTOMERS THROUGH A
STE FOR. MONTHS A MONTH
MEMBERSHIP AGREEMENT INSTEAD OF
THROUGH TRADITIONAL SALE LEASE
OR RENTAL METHODS. AS A RESULT
OF COVER NINETEEN CALIFORNIA
SHED A RECORD TWO POINT THREE
FOUR MILLION JOBS RESULTING IN
A FIFTEEN POINT FIVE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE THESE DIRE
ECONOMIC NUMBERS HAVE
TRANSLATED. INTO DECLINES IN
NEW CAR SALES OF APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY FOUR PERCENT. MANY
CONCURRENT DECREASE IN STATE
AND LOCAL SALES TAXES. THE
CURRENT VIRUS ALSO DECIMATED
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET ALL BUT
ENSURING THE TV AND SENATE SUCH
AS CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROGRAMS OF YOUR P. WILL BE
ELIMINATED. THE COMBINATION OF
HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT PLUNGING NEW
CAR SALES. AND THE ELIMINATION
OF STATE EVEY INCENTIVE WILL
MAKE IT VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE.
FOR THE STATE TO MEET ITS GOAL
OF FIVE MILLION THE VIS BY
TWENTY THIRTY. AND SO IT'S OUR
BELIEF THAT ESTABLISHING THE
LEGAL FRAMEWORK PROPOSED IN
THIS BILL. WILL COST THE STATE
VERY LITTLE WHILE PROVIDING
CALIFORNIA DRIVERS ACCESS TO
MONTHLY MEMBERSHIPS. WHICH WILL
BE PRICE LOWER THAN THE COST OF
MANY LEASE AGREEMENTS END WHICH
THEY CAN CANCEL WITHOUT.
FINANCIAL PENALTIES. IN THIS
WILL HELP TO RIGHT THE SHIP
WITH REGARDS TO OUR PLANS TO
GET MORE ELECTRIC VEHICLES ON
TO THE ROAD. ALSO UNDER THIS
NEW LEGAL FRAMEWORK DRIVERS
WOULD BENEFIT FROM
COMPREHENSIVE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS. MANUFACTURES
OFFERING MEMBERSHIPS MAJID HERE
TO ROBUST VEHICLE RECALL
PROVISIONS AND FOLLOW ALL
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS ESTABLISHED
BY THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT. MEMBERS THIS BILL
IS NECESSARY BECAUSE IT
PROVIDES CONSUMERS WITH SAFE.
LOWER COST OPTION TO GET INTO
THE V. WITHOUT RISKY FINANCING
A LONG TERM COMMITMENTS. THAT'S
GIVING PEOPLE MORE FAMILIARITY
WITH THIS TECHNOLOGY AND IN A
IN A LOWER KEY MANNER. PROVIDES
EVEY BENEFACTORS AWAY TO
SUCCESSFULLY MARKET THIRTY VIS
DURING CHALLENGE CHALLENGING
ECONOMIC TIMES IT HELPS TO
OFFSET THE LOST OF A C.
EUROPEAN CENTERS AT ALMOST NO
COST TO THE STATE. ANNA HELPS
CALIFORNIA MINUTES GOAL OF
HAVING FIVE MILLION VIEWS ON
OUR ROADS BY TWENTY THIRTY THE
BILL SUPPORTED BY CONSUMERS FOR
ON A ROUTE LARA BILL AND SEE.
THE LA ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
COUNCIL NUMEROUS AND GROUPS
SUCH AS COMFORTABLY
CONSERVATION VOTERS CLUB AS
WELL AS OF COURSE EVEY
MANUFACTURES. ALL RIGHT NOW THE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IS
GOING TO A ARGUE THAT ONLY
BENEFITS ONE COMPANY THIS IS
SIMPLY NOT ACCURATE. YES A
CALIFORNIA EVEY MANUFACTURE
CANOE IS THE LEGISLATION
SPONSOR. BUT TV COMPANY REVIEW
N. AS IN SUPPORT OTHER EATING
THAT AFFECTIONS LIKE FERRET A
LUCID ARE ALSO ELIGIBLE. FOR
THE BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS BILL. THE OPPOSITION'S
ALSO COULD ARGUE THAT
MANUFACTURES COULD DO THIS
UNDER CURRENT LAW IF THEY JUST
GOT A CAR DEALERS LICENSE. BUT
THESE MANUFACTURES ARE NOT
SELLING CARS THEY'RE THEY'RE
NOT. GONNA HAVE BRICK AND
MORTAR STORE THE CONSUMER TO
PURCHASE THE VEHICLE. IN AS
OPPONENTS KNOW DEALERSHIPS ARE
TECHNIQUE FORBIDDEN FROM
OFFERING MONTH TO MONTH
MEMBERSHIPS BECAUSE OF
RESTRICTIONS IN LEASING. AND
VEHICLE RENTAL LOSS. UNDER THIS
BILL EVEY MANUFACTURES WILL OWN
MAINTAIN AND EVEN HELP
FACILITATE. THE CHARGING OF THE
VEHICLES THEY ARE OFFERING ON A
MEMBERSHIP BASIS. IF THE CAR
NEEDS TO BE REPLACED A
METAFICTIONAL SIMPLY REPLACE IT
ALL THIS IS NOT SOMETHING A CAR
DEALERS DO. LASTLY THE
OPPOSITION MAY ARGUE TODAY THAT
THEY ARE EXCLUDED FROM THE
FRAMEWORK OF THE BILL. IF YOU
DO THAT YOU MIGHT CONSIDER
ASKING THEM IF THEY WANT TO BE
INCLUDED IN WHETHER THEY BE
INCLUDED WOULD IN FACT REMOVE
THEIR OPPOSITION TO THIS
LEGISLATION- THEIR ANSWERS WILL
BE ELIMINATING WE ACTUALLY HAD
A VERY ROBUST. YOUR POSITIVE
CONVERSATION WITH THEM. THE
OTHER DAY I WAS ON THE CALL AS
WAS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL. AND
YOU KNOW WHAT UNFORTUNATELY
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN WILLING TO
ENGAGE. IN NEGOTIATIONS HAVE
NOT PROVIDED US WITH
AMENDMENTS- BUT YOU KNOW- HAVE
VERY HAPPY. I KNOW THE AUTHORS
VERY HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN IT WITH
THAT CONVERSATION IF THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S MEANINGFUL TO
THEM. THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT
OUR ELECTRIC VEHICLE PURCHASES
ARE IN DECLINE OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS IN FOR SERIOUS ABOUT
MEETING OUR CLINICAL AS WE HAVE
TO INNOVATE. AND WITH THE
PROPER CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN
PLACE WE MUST PROVIDE. NEW
PATHWAYS TO INCENTIVIZE EVEY
ADOPTION. AND WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESSES BOTH OF WHOM ARE
TESTIFYING BY PHONE. ENTER LOST
IN FROM CANOEING AND ROSE MARIE
STAND AS THE PRESIDENT OF
CONSUMERS FOR AUTO RELIABILITY
AND SAFETY. THANK YOU- SENATOR
ALLEN- WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THOSE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND YOU LISTED YOUR-
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE. AND WILL STAND FROM
CANOE AND ROSE MERRY SHANNON.
FROM CONSUMERS FOR AUTO AUTO
RELIABILITY. AND WE'LL START
WITH MR WILL STAND- MISTER WILL
STATE ARE YOU WITH US. I AM
OKAY YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN BELL AND THANK YOU
CENTER ALLEN FOR THE
INTRODUCTION AND THE THANK YOU
TO ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO PRESENT TO DISCUSS THIS
BILL. CAN YOU ELECTRIC VEHICLE
MANUFACTURER BASED IN TORRANCE
WITH THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE EACH
YEAR IN CALIFORNIA. ROUTE TO BE
A SPONSOR AB THREE TO SIX
BECAUSE WE VIEW IT AS A
CRITICAL. STEP IN MEETING
CALIFORNIA-DRIVERS-PAY-UNDERFUNDED-STATE-PATROL-PENSION
THE COMPUTER SO MANY HEALTH.
AND NOW. NOT HAVING THE
CALIFORNIA EVEY INCENTIVES
AVAILABLE CREDIT EVEY CELLS
EVEN HARDER THE- FUTURE. THIS
BILL GIVES EVEN INDUSTRY AND
ALL TURN MODEL TO GET MORE TV'S
PRODUCE GET MORE CUSTOMERS
NDTV'S. AND MOST PRESSING GIVEN
THE ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY WE'RE
EXPERIENCING KEEP MORE OF THE
ESTIMATED. SEVENTY FIVE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE AFFILIATED
INDUSTRY EMPLOYEES WORKING IN
CALIFORNIA. WE LOOK AT THE
REGULATORY LANDSCAPING
CALIFORNIA FOR AUTO OFFERINGS
AND OUR MEMBERSHIP MODEL WOULD
FIT ENOUGH BRING THE ANSWER
UNCLEAR. FROM SOME OF THIS
OFFER WAS ALREADY PASTA UNDER.
LAWS IT'S A GREAT SO WE FACE
TWO OPTIONS ONE. AS FORD AND
UNCERTAIN ENVIRONMENT FOR THE
COMPANY CONSUMERS AND RISK
HAVING TO BE BACK HERE BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE LIKE MANY OTHERS
IN THE PAST AND HAVE TO BE HERE
ASKING FOR FORGIVENESS. OR TWO
WE COULD'VE BEEN PRO ACTIVE
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE KEY GROUPS THAT HAVE COME
UNDER SUPPORT THIS BILL. CREATE
A CLEAR CONSUMER FRIENDLY
FRAMEWORK GIVES A CLEAR PATH TO
PRODUCING MORE TV'S AND GETTING
THEM. AND THE CALIFORNIA.
WELCOME NINETEEN IS BROUGHT
INTO THE ON ECONOMIC
DEVASTATION THE CALIFORNIA THE
CLIMATE EMERGENCY STILL REMAINS
AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT. SO THE
ECONOMIC SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT IS NOT
AVAILABLE WE'RE PROUD TO
SPONSOR AB THREE TO SIX THE
REVENUE NEUTRAL BILL I CAN HELP
CALIFORNIA GET CLOSER TO ITS
CRITICAL EVEY TARGET. MANNER
THAT IS MORE CONSUMER FRIENDLY
THAN ANY OTHER COMPARABLE FOR.
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER WILLSTAND ON ROSE MERRY
SHOT HAN- IT'S JUST LET'S HEAR
FROM YOU THANK YOU. THE
CHAIRMAN FALLON AND MEMBERS I'M
ROSEMARY SHEA HAND PRESIDENT
CONSUMERS FOR AUTO RELIABILITY
AND SAFETY OR CARS CARS IS AN
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT AUTO
SAFETY AND CONSUMER ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION WE HAVE SPONSORED
NUMEROUS CONSUMER PROTECTION
LAWS ENACTED IN CALIFORNIA. AND
WASHINGTON DC TO IMPROVE
PROTECTIONS FOR NEW AND USED
CAR BUYERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
THREE TO SIX. NOW WHEN MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE LOST THEIR
JOBS OR HAD THEIR INCOMES
DRASTICALLY REDUCED AND
MILLIONS MORE FACE UNCERTAINTY
REGARDING THEIR ECONOMIC
FUTURES CONSUMERS ARE
UNDERSTANDABLY WARY OF ENTERING
INTO LONG TERM LEASES WHICH OP
AT HIS HEART OR LUNG. WHICH MAY
LAST FOR A YEAR. THERE OFFERS
IN. LOWER RISK ALTERNATIVE FREE
CONSUME WHO WE TO GIVE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES TRY. FROM HAVING TO
ENTER A LONG TERM FINANCIAL
COMMITMENT PARTICULARLY DURING
A PANDEMIC TO COOK FROM THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS THE
STRONGEST CONSUMER PROTECTION
IS INHERENT IN THE MODEL ITSELF
WHICH IS THE RELATIVELY SHORT
NOTICE OR NOT MORE THAN TWO
MONTHS TO DISCONTINUE THE
MEMBERSHIP. WITH THE MOST
RECENT IN BAD NOTICE PERIOD IF
THE ARE ADOPTED IN THIS
COMMITTEE- WILL BE SHORTENED
EVEN FURTHER TO FORTY FIVE DAYS.
CURRENTLY THE AVERAGE AGE OF
THE VEHICLE REGISTERED IN
CALIFORNIA'S OVER ELEVEN YEARS.
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
WRITING IN VEHICLES WITH
OUTMODED SAFETY FATURESTHAT
OFFER FAR LESS PROTECTION THE
NEWER VEHICLES WITH MORE
ADVANCED SAFETY FEATURES THAT'S
PARTICULARLY FOR PARTLY DUE TO
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN.
NEGATIVE EQUITY CAUSED BY LONG
TERM LOANS IT MUST BE REPAID
EVEN AFTER THE CAR'S SCRAPPED
OR TRADED IN. AB THREE TO SIX
OFFERS A NEW OPTION FOR
CONSUMERS THAT WILL HELP
ACCELERATE THE REPLACEMENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S AGING VEHICLE
FLEET WITH NEWER SAFER CLEANER
VEHICLES. NEWER VEHICLES WITH
MORE ADVANCED SAFETY
TECHNOLOGIES DRAMATICALLY
REDUCE THE RISK OF DEATH AND
INJURY. FINALLY AB THREE TO SIX
WILL ALSO HELP IMPROVE
COMPLIANCE WITH AUTO SAFETY
RECALLS DUE TO SERIOUS DEFECTS
UNFORTUNATELY MANY DEALERS
PERSISTENT SELLING DANGEROUS
RECALL USED VEHICLES IN OUR
STATE WITHOUT OBTAINING THE
FREE REPAIRS VERSUS. IN
CONTRAST AB THREE TO SIX
REQUIRES ELECTRIC. MOBILITY
MANUFACTURERS TO ENSURE THAT
SAFETY RECALLS TO PERFORM
BEFORE RENEWING MEMBERSHIP. FOR
ALL OF THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU MRS JOHN AND
NOW LET'S TURN TO OUR OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND-
SENATE GALLERY ANYBODY I DON'T
SEE ANYBODY.OKAY ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE TO SIX. AND I SEE
NONE. THANK YOU WE'LL NOW MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAY TO TESTIFIED
BE VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
TO SIX AND WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAN THEIR ROLE. AN OPERATOR
WILL PICTURE LINE NUMBER IN
PROVIDE YOU THAT. WHEN OUR
MILITARY MEN FOR THE FIRST
NUMBER. THANK. THE MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE ME THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SPITE NOW MAHOOD
SHERMAN. WE HAVE THREE PEOPLE
LINE UP NOW PRAYER OKAY THANK
YOU MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND CALL
SUPPORT NGUYEN DISS
INDIVIDUALLY WE WILL CONTINUE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN LINE
NUMBER TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TO BE AN ATTACKER WITH
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA. WITH THE AMENDMENTS
AGREED TO OVER THE WEEKEND AT
THE CRACK BY SENATOR. YEAR YOUR
MOVIE OPPOSITION AND THE BALLOT
THE COURT. CALIFORNIA POLICY
THAT PROTECT ENVIRONMENT BUT
ALSO PROTECTS THE CONSUMER IN
EIGHTY THREE TO SIX OPPOSED BE
AMENDED TRACK THAT DOWN.
EAGERLY OF THE CHAIR AND BOTH
AUTHORED AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS AARON
RODRIGUEZ WITH UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MY NUMBER NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS DAN LAST TIME THE
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY AT
MERIDIAN RADIAN ELECTRIC TRUCK
COMPANY EMPLOYING HUNDREDS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THOUSANDS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY WE SUPPORT IT THREE
TWENTY SIX AS AMENDED BECAUSE
WE THINK IT IS A CREATIVE WAY
TO HELP EXPAND ELECTRIC VEHICLE
ADOPTION IN CALIFORNIA. TO HELP
THE STATE REACHES CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION AND POLLUTION
REDUCTION GOALS THANK YOU. AND
THAT THIS OF THE TERM THAT WAS
OUR LAST. THANK YOU. OKAY ONE
LAST CALL KERN MODERATE COULD
YOU PLEASE CHECK THE LINE AGAIN
ONCE AGAIN TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON AB THREE TO SIX.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OF AB TWENTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE TO SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. IN AT THIS TIME OF
THE GERMAN WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
THANK MODERATOR AND NOT HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS.
WE WILL NOW FALLTHE SAME
PROCESS. AND HEAR FROM.
OPPOSITION TO A. B. THREE TO
SIX. LET'S START WITH WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
SENATE GALLERY. AND ERA WE WILL
HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION NOW.
AND. YES SIR THERE FOR YOURSELF
AND STATE YOUR POSITION. MISTER
CHAIR AND SENATORS CLIP COSTA
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NEW
CAR DEALERS ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL BUT STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
OVERALL CALIFORNIA'S NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION BELIEVES
THIS BILL CREATED. FOR VEHICLE
SUBSCRIPTIONS WHICH IS A
NECESSARY UNFAIRLY COMPETES
AGAINST EXISTING DEALER
LICENSEES AND IS HARMFUL FOR
CONSUMERS VEHICLE SUBSCRIPTIONS
ARE ARE BEING OFFERED TODAY BY
CALIFORNIA'S DEALERS EITHER
THROUGH PROGRAMS OFFERED BY
AUTOMAKERS DEALERS SUCH AS BOOK
BY CADILLAC OR THROUGH APPS
LIKE FOR IN CLUTCH. THIS
INCLUDES THE EXACT TYPE OF
SUBSCRIPTIONS AUTHORIZED BY
THIS BILL AND IS CURRENTLY
BEING OFFERED BY D. M. V.
LICENSED CAR DEALERS. BECAUSE
OF THAT WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL IS UNNECESSARY AS THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AND
ANYONE ELSE COULD JUST BE A
LICENSED CAR DEALER AND WE FAIL
TO SEE BY THE EXISTING CAR
DEALER LICENSING LAWS. PARENTS
OF CREATING THIS NEW PATH.
ADDITIONALLY WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL UNFAIRLY PREVENTS THE
ABILITY OF EXISTING DEALERS TO
BE INNOVATIVE AS WELL. VEHICLE
SUBSCRIPTION PROGRAMS ARE STILL
EVOLVING IN THE AUTO RETAIL
MARKET AND IT'S UNCLEAR WHICH
TYPES OF PROGRAMS WILL SUCCEED.
BUT THIS BILL CREATES AN UNFAIR
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE FOR THIS
NEW CATEGORY BY STATUTORILY
PROHIBITING YOUR LOCAL NEW CAR
DEALER FROM PARTICIPATING IN OR
OFFERING THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS TO THEIR CUSTOMERS.
ARE DEALERS WANT TO BE PART OF
INNOVATIVE NEW APPROACHES TO
RETAILING VEHICLES AND THIS
pBILL STATUTORILY PROHIBITS.
FINALLY WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
LACKS THE IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS AN ACTIVE OVER
THE LAST FIFTY YEARS AGAINST
CAR DEALERS. THESE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS PREVENT CONSUMERS
FROM FRAUD GENTLY SIGNING
SOMETHING THEY DO NOT
UNDERSTAND. BEING MISLED BY AN
ACCURATE ADVERTISING OR DRIVING
A VEHICLE HICH MAY BE FLOODED
SALVAGED OR TOTAL LOSS WITHOUT
BEING DISCLOSED. WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT NOW IS THE TIME TO
WE- DRAW. OR USE AN ELECTRIC
VEHICLE AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOU
KNOW BUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN THE SENATE GALLERY WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK. AT ONE MORE. YES
SIR PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF
THANK. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JOHN MOFFITT ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR AUTOMOTIVE
INNOVATION WE ARE THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR THE
MANUFACTURERS OF NINE POINT 9%
OF THE VEHICLES ON AMERICA'S
ROADS TODAY WE SUPPORTING HE
SINGS AB SALES WHICH SUPPORT
SUBSCRIPTION PROGRAMS WE ARE
OPPOSED AB THREE TWENTY SIX FOR
A NUMBER OF REASONS. FOR BUILD
IT. AT THAT LATE TO COMPANIES
TO THE EXPRESS EXCLUSION OF ALL
OF MY MEMBER COMPANIES WHO
INCIDENTALLY ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE VAST MAJORITY OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES OUT ON
CALIFORNIA'S ROADS TODAY.
SENATOR ALLEN RAISE THE
QUESTION IF IT DID INCLUDE US
WHAT WE SUPPORT NO. BECAUSE THE
BILL IS NOT NECESSARY
SUBSCRIPTION PROGRAMS ARE NOT
NOVEL THEY ARE NOT UNIQUE AND
THEY ARE NOT PROHIBITED BY
EXISTING LAW. IT IS NOT THE
TIME TO GO AND CODIFY ONE
BUSINESS MODEL TO THE EXCLUSION
OF ALL OTHERS MANY OF MY MEMBER
COMPANIES ARE OFFERING
SUBSCRIPTION PILOT PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING AND OTHERS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. WE
SHOULD NOT BE MOVING THIS BILL
FORWARD AT THE BEHEST OF A
HANDFUL OF COMPANIES WITHOUT
THE INPUT WHO HAVE YET TO
MANUFACTURE VEHICLE. AND
EXCLUDING THE INPUT. OF
COMPANIES THAT HAVE BEEN
MANUFACTURING AND SELLING
VEHICLES FOR OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS. SENATOR ALLEN NOTED IN
NUMBER OF RATIONALES FOR MOVING
THE BILL FORWARD TODAY VEHICLE
OF A AVAILABILITY PRICING IN
SOME PLACES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHEN YOU TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT STATE. FEDERAL AND
LOCAL INCENTIVES YOU CAN GET
INTO A ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
FOR ZERO DOLLARS. THE CHALLENGE
WITH GETTING SAYS OUT ON THE
ROAD TODAY IS NOT VEHICLE
AVAILABILITY. IT IS CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE THESE ARE THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO BE
ADDRESSING. THIS BILL. IS AN
ATTEMPT TO TRY AND CODIFY A
BUSINESS MODEL THAT DOESN'T
NEED TO HAPPEN AND IT CERTAINLY
DOESN'T NEED TO HAPPEN RIGHT
NOW. I'M MORE THAN WILLING TO
ENGAGE IN A CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE SUBSCRIPTION PROGRAM WE'VE
BEEN. LOOKING AT HOW TO MAKE
THESE WORK FOR CONSUMERS FOR
THE LAST DECADE AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO PROVIDE INPUT. BUT CERTAINLY
NOT ON A LAST MINUTE GOT AMEND
BILL THAT THAT SHOULDN'T BE
MOVING FORWARD. AT THE AT THE
LAST MINUTE IN A CODED
TRUNCATED SESSION. WE ARE
OPPOSED WE ASK FOR YOU KNOW
ABOUT THANK. THANK YOU SIR AND-
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY ON I DON'T SEE
ANY. SO WE WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY AND WE WANT TO
FIND OUT THERE'S ANYWHERE DISS
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHO WAS
TESTIFIED. IN OPPOSITION. AB.
THREE TO SIX. AND I SEE NONE
THANK YOU. AND AT THIS POINT
WILL NOW MOVES TO ON TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA OUR TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO A.
B. THREE TO SIX AND WE WILL
BEGIN MODERATOR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AB THREE TO SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE DIDN'T THEIR
ROLE. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH LINE NUMBER IN
PLACE YOU BACK INTO THE CALL.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITE IN A. B. THREE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE NOW. IN ONE MOMENT
THE GERMAN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND WE DO HAVE
SOMEONE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
LINE NUMBER TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI I'M ACTUALLY I TRIED TO GET
THROUGH SPEAKING IN SUPPORT I
AND WE ARE IN THIS IS JULIE
AROUND OFF WITH THE COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR AND WE'RE AT THE
PORT I COULD NOT GET THROUGH
EARLIER. WHEN YOU CALLED. THANK
YOU. PEOPLE WAITED TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. THAT WAS THE
ONLY PERSON THERE. OKAY THANK
YOU MODERATOR NOW IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES IN CALL.
A ONE LAST TIME FOR OPPOSITION
WITNESSES AND WE WILL CONTINUE
ONE LAST TIME FOR OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB THREE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB THREE
TO SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THEY
DID THEIR OWN NOW. AND AT THIS
TIME OF DETERMINE WE HAVE NO
ONE. OKAY NO THANK YOU FOR OUR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES AND WE WILL NOW BRING
TO DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR
MEMBERS NOW IF THE MEMBERS WISH
TO ASK QUESTIONS OF ANY SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION WITNESSES YOU CAN
ASK THE MODERATE TO OPEN THE
LINE FOR THE SPECIFIC PERSON-
OF MAINE'S MAIN OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORTERS AND WE CAN HAVE
DIALOGUE. CAN HAPPEN SO DO ANY
OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SIR WHY
KOWSKI HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
MANAGER OF THE BILL THEY-
EXPRESS ENTHUSIASM BY THE
AUTHOR IN THE MANAGER TO RIGHT
THE SHIP- IF THE CONCERN FOR
THE GOAL HERE IS TO GET ACCESS
TO CONSUMERS I WAS EVEN. MODEL
THAT WE HAVE THAT THEIR DATA
AVAILABLE AND I SEE THAT THIS
IS NOT THE BILL THIS IS THE
BILL SAYS IT'S ONLY THESE
MANUFACTURES IT ONLY MAKE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES BUT IF THE
ENVIRONMENT THE GOAL WAS JUST.
EVERY E. V. THAT EXIST
CALIFORNIA TO GET IT OUT ON THE
ROAD AND HAVE THIS. WHY WOULD
YOU NOT INCLUDE. A BROADER
SPECTRUM OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CONSUMERS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
SOME. MEMBERSHIP PROGRAM THAT
INCLUDED ALL TYPES OF
BUSINESSES THAT I CAN'T EVEN
THINK OF RIGHT. YEAH IT'S A
THROUGH THE CHAIR- CENTERONE
OKAY SO FIRST OF ALL AND THIS
BILL. HI A NASTY FORM WAS IN
PRINT FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
OF THE YEAR AND I THINK WE WERE
WE'RE VERY INTERESTED AT LEAST
I KNOW THAT I KNOW I CAN SPEAK
FOR BOTH MYSELF AND FOR THE A
STUNNER RCG WE'RE VERY
INTERESTED IN ENGAGING. THE FOR
THE FOR THIS AND TO TALK ABOUT
THEM IT'S A AND I THINK THE
REAL OPENNESS TO INCLUDE. THEM
I THINK THAT DAY. HAVE BEEN SO
OF TO THE GENERAL IDEA. THAT
WOULD OPEN UP FOR THIS THIS
TYPE OF OWNERSHIP. THAT THEY
JUST I'M WILLING TO ENGAGE US
IN INCOME SESSIONS ABOUT
AMENDMENTS I THINK I MISSED
YOUR QUESTION IS COULD. I AM
VERY QUESTION OF THE OPPOSITION
ON A CALL THIS YESTERDAY. IN
THE TO DECIDE THEY REALLY WANT
TO. KILL THE AS OPPOSED GAUGE
AND CON. OF HOW TO. THEIR
PRODUCTS IN. THIS IN THIS
MECHANISM SO. I THINK MAYBE
WHAT WE OUGHT TO DO IS THE BILL
MOVES FLORIDA JUST UNILATERALLY
COME UP. I WAITED YOU JUST
WHICH IS WHAT YOU DESCRIBED. I
THINK WE WERE HOPING THAT WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO DO CONJUNCTION
WITH. THE ISLANDS WITH THE
OPPONENTS WHO WHO MAKE OURS
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. HI SO
THAT'S IT ALLEN'S AND- BUT I
AGREE WITH YOUR PREMISE AND I
DON'T THINK THAT- THAT- TAT
THE SUMMER CITY DISAGREES
EITHER I THINK I THINK THERE'S
A- A REAL INTERESTING TRYING TO
BE. THIS A MECHANISM. TO ALLOW
MORE YOUNG PEOPLE AND PEOPLE
FROM ALL DIFFERENT STRIDES TO
GAIN GREATER. ACCOMMODATION
WITH THESE TYPES OF CARS AND
THIS IS THE THIS IS A LOW KEY
SAFE LOWER COST WAY OF GETTING
THESE CARS INTO MORE PEOPLE'S
HANDS AND MAKE THEM FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH- WITH YOU WITH
THE FEES. AND THAT'S EXACTLY
THE GOLF SO LOVE TO WORK WITH
YOU ON ON ON HOW TO DO THAT-
EVEN IF WE'RE NOT ABLE TO. HI
ENGAGE IN A IN A REAL.
CONVERSATION WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND IN THIS MONTH.
MISTER CHAIR IRAQ OUSTED I
WOULDN'T CONSIDER MYSELF A
JOINER I DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
MEMBERSHIP- OR JUST DON'T SEE
TO THE JOINT MEMBERSHIPS BUT I
THINK THAT THIS MAY BE THE
BEGINNING OF. SOME OF THESE
OPPORTUNITIES AND THIS IS THE
BUSINESS OF THE A ONE OF THE
EARLY- BILLS ARE COMING BEFORE
US AND FORTUNATELY MISTER
CHAIR. I BELIEVE THIS MAY BE
YOUR LAST HEARING THAT YOU'RE
HAVING A SENATE TRANSPORTATION-
COMMITTEE- BUT- I'M- WITH THE
MOMENT SIR GIVING I THINK I'M
IN A POSITION TO SUPPORT THIS-
THIS MODEL AND I'M I VIEWED IN
ITS EMBRYONIC STAGE IN MAYBE
THEY'LL BE OTHER. OTHER
DISCUSSIONS COMING FORWARD ON
ALL TYPES OF MEMBERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND I DO AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES WHICH IS STATED THAT
ARE MY CONCERN WELL AS HIS IS
THE BROADER OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
MORE PEOPLE THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT I BELIEVE IS IMPORTANT I
THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT WE
NEED MORE ELECTRIC FIELD. THAT
THE CHARTER. TWENTY TO BE
INNOVATIVE THAT. WHICH IS THE
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THIS
WORKS- I KNOW THAT CENTER
STATED THAT THIS IS BEEN IN
FRANCE SINCE EARLY THIS YEAR
BUT TO BE FAIR WE HAVEN'T BEEN
HERE ALL YOUR PACK AND I WAS
UNDER THE IMPRESSION. BEFORE I
DID ANY EVENT YOU KNOW TAKE A
LOOK AND I KNOW THAT IT WAS
JUST GUIDED IN AMENDED THE
ASSEMBLY TWO WEEKS AGO. AND
WHAT I BELIEVE IS THIS IS ONE
OF THOSE ISSUES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT BUT IT ALSO NEEDS. TO
BRING. POLICY AND THERE AND I
CONSIDER TO BE ONE OF THOSE
STAKEHOLDERS AND I THINK THAT
WE WOULD BE BETTER SERVED IF WE%
HAD. AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING
ALL RIGHT NOW I'M STRUGGLING TO
EVEN UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SUBSCRIPTION MODEL
VERSUS THE LEASE MODEL WHY DO
SOME DEALERS HAVE AT Y. EIGHT.
OTHERS AND- I ALSO BELIEVE THAT
IF WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW ALL THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE COME TO DO
THAT. WHY NOT AT. ALL OTHER ARM
CAR DEALERSHIPS. SOMETHING I
REALLY- IMPORTANT THAT I
BELIEVE THE PRESENTER BUT RIGHT
NOW IS THAT. DISCOVER NINETY.
FORTY IN JOB. IT'S AN- I WOULD.
THE I. SAID NOT. YES PEOPLE WHO
THEIR JOB THIS IS A PART BUT IN
A STATE THAT I HAVE. HER FAMILY
FUNCTIONS ON CAR DEALERSHIP AND
TAX REVENUE. WHEN I ARMS LIKE
MY THAT HAVE PART. AND I STILL
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE AND IS WHAT
IS THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
OF THIS ARE MY CAR DEALERSHIPS
CLINT POINT TO GO OUT OF. AND
I'M NOT IMPLYING ARE BUT THAT
JUST. BIGGER QUESTION SHOULD WE
HAVE MORE TIME TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND IT. AND ALSO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE IS
MOVING THIS DIRECTION I'D GET
INFORMATIONAL HEARING WITH
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS WOULD
ALLOW MORE PEOPLE TO. JOIN AND
PARKS PAGE UNDERSTAND. RIGHT
NOW I THINK IT'S SAD TO
PREMATURE FOR ME TO TRY AND
SUPPORT. ONLY BECAUSE I KNOW
I'VE HAD CALLS THE LAST FOUR
DAYS FROM ALL THE CAR
DEALERSHIPS IN MY AND MY
DISTRICT AND AT THE VERY LEAST
I HAVE TO KNOW WITH CERTAINTY
THAT I DEBT AT THE ISSUE I
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE. AND
THAT'S WHY VOTER FURNISHING
RIGHT NOW. I JUST SAW THE
ANALYSIS I THINK FOUR DAYS AGO
AND IT'S ENOUGH TIME FOR ME TO
ENGAGE IN OR PAGE. THE R. TO BE
FAIR I HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR ANY OTHER. OR SET POINT.
THIS WITH PEOPLE PARTICIPATING
ALL OF US TRULY ARE. WHAT THE
AND IS GOING TO BE SO THIS
POINT I GOING TO HAVE TO. OUR
STAFF AND SEE IF I CAN GET MORE
AND- THANK YOU. OKAY BELIEVE
CENTER. TANNER OF WOULD LIKE TO
A- SERVICE AND- CENTER DODD AND
SENATOR BATES OKAY. SO CENTER
SKINNER. YES SENATOR SKINNER
HERE- A QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR
SENATOR ALLEN YOU REFERENCED
THE AND THAT IN YOUR
PRESENTATION. THAT THERE WAS.
THE OFFER AS I UNDERSTAND IT
FROM THE AUTHOR CHIU INCLUDE
CAR DEALERSHIPS IN THIS MODEL
IS THAT CORRECT AND THEY CHOSE
NOT TO BE. YES THAT THAT IS
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT THE
DIGIT. BROADLY SPEAKING YES
THAT'S CORRECT. IS IT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY HAVE A
COMPARABLE SUBSCRIPTION SERVICE
AVAILABLE NOW TO CAR
DEALERSHIPS IT'S SO IT'S THEIR
SIMILARITIES BUT IT'S DIFFERENT
THE WHAT WHAT SO THEY HAVE
SUBSCRIPTION PROGRAMS WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE SO
THAT THAT'S WHERE ONE CAR IS
SHARED BY MANY LIKE ZIPCARS FOR
EXAMPLE WHERE IS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A MEMBERSHIP PROGRAM
WHERE YOU ACTUALLY TAKE. YOU
KNOW A CAR HOME YOU KNOW HOME
LINE OWNERSHIP AND SO THE IDEA
IS YOU KEEP THE CAR UNLESS OR
UNTIL IT NEEDS TO BE REPLACED
OR THE MEMBERSHIP ENDS AND SO
THAT'S A MONTH TO MONTH SYSTEM
BY THE WAY THEY'RE ALL PAYING
TAXES NOT THEM HE'S GOING TO
DELIVER GOVERNMENTS AND- I DID.
NECESSARILY TO GIVE MORE TO
FLESH OUT THE MODEL MORE IF YOU
LIKE SENATOR. WELL I'VE READ
THE MODEL. THE I BELIEVE THE
NOT BELIEVE DâN NOW ASSIST
DESCRIBES THE MODEL QUITE WELL.
JACK I WANT TO SHAKE- COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR A REALLY EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS WHICH DOES GIVE US A
GOOD AMOUNT OF DETAIL ON THE
MODEL- I THINK THE
CLARIFICATION I ASK IS THAT.
THE OPPOSITION. RAISED THAT.
THAT THIS WAS NOT NECESSARY AND
I FEEL THAT IT. IT DOES NOT
UNFAIRLY COMPETE WITH OUR CAR
DEALERSHIPS BECAUSE THEY WOULD
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN SOMETHING LIKE
THIS IF THEY CHOOSE AND
CERTAINLY COULD THAT IF THE ARM
IF ART THING STATUTES IN ANY
WAY RESTRICT THEY CHOSE NOT TO
BE PART OF THIS WE CAN ADDRESS
THAT. I AM IN A SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY BECAUSE I THINK THAT
THIS TYPE OF ARRANGEMENT I MEAN
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT CAR SHARE
AND THAT WHEN I IN MY FORMER
PRIOR BEING LEGISLATURE AND I
RAN IT ORGANIZATION THAT RAN
THE PROGRAM CITIES FOR CLIMATE
PROTECTION WE WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE GRANTS TO. LOCAL FOR
INNOVATIVE PROJECTS TO BRING
DOWN TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS
AND INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH. IN
THE EARLY NINETIES WE PROVIDED
THE VERY FIRST FUNDING TO THE
FIRST TWO CITIES THAT EVER GET
HARSHER PROGRAMS WHICH WERE
SANTA MONICA IN PORTLAND. THIS
AGAIN WAS IN THE EARLY NINETIES.
THEY WERE UNABLE TO EXPAND
THEIR PARSER PROGRAMS. LET JUST
US STATUTES IN ALMOST EVERY
STATE PROHIBITED PARK HERE IN
TOOK YEARS TO FIX THE STATUTES.
AND YET WE NOW APPRECIATE AND
UNDERSTAND THE VERY IMPORTANT
ROLE FOR OUR SHARE YOU AT FOR
THOSE PEOPLE WHO DON'T WISH TO
ONLY FAR NOW IN THIS CASE WE
HAVE AS CALIFORNIA. AND VICIOUS
SCHOOLS. TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS REDUCTION AND FOR
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES ON THE ROAD.
AND YET WE KNOW THAT MANY
PEOPLE MANY OF US WE BUY A NEW
CAR INFREQUENTLY. AND SO TO
TAKE THE TO MAKE THE LEAP OF
FAITH TO BUY A VERY NEW
TECHNOLOGY. IS OUR IS DIFFICULT
FOR MANY PEOPLE AND SO DO YOU.
TO BE ABLE TO GET CONCORD USING
A NEW TECHNOLOGY FOR TWO MONTHS
THREE MONTHS SIX MONTHS BEFORE
WHEN. YEAH THINK IS A REALLY
GOOD SERVICE THAT PROVIDES AN
WOULD HELP US. ON CALIFORNIA'S
NOWHERE NEAR EATING ITS GOALS
OF. ARTS ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
THAT WERE ONE OF THE ROADS FOR
OUR TRANSPORTATION EMISSION
REDUCTION. SO I THINK THAT THIS
IS ONE OF THOSE INNOVATIONS
THAT. I NEEDED AND I THINK THAT.
I DO NOT SEE IT AS THE TYPE OF
THREAT THAT OUR CAR DEALERSHIPS
CURRENTLY SEE BUT CERTAINLY WE
HAVE THE ABILITY AS THE
LEGISLATURE. THERE ARE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES TO
ADJUST OUR STATUTES IN THE
FUTURE THAT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. THANK YOU
CENTER THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER
DODD AND THEN SENATOR BASED AT
THE LEAST YES MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I BELIEVE
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM FREMONT
WAS QUOTING. GROUCHO MARX. WERE
YOU ANYBODY THAT WOULD HAVE YOU
AS A MEMBER YOU WOULD NOT. I
JOIN THAT ORGANIZATION BUT
NEVER THE LESS. HI ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITH THAT OF A CENTER
SKINNER I THINK THOSE ARE OF
YOUR VERY STREET. COMMENTS CAR
DEALERS RIGHT NOW HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO SUBSCRIPTION
SERVICES. IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THIS IS JUST A CASE WHERE WE
HAVE A COMPETITOR THE DOESN'T
WANT TO SEE SOMEBODY ELSE ORDER
ORGANIZATION OF COMPETITORS
THAT DOESN'T WANT TO SEE NEW
INNOVATION LIKE THIS HAPPENED
AND GET THEM INTO THE MARKET.
SO THEY'VE GOT SO MUCH TIME
THEY CAN EITHER GET WITH THE
PROGRAM TO GET THE SAME THING
OR I THINK WE SHOULD I THINK WE
SHOULD THIS TODAY THIS BILL OUT
MY SUPPORT. THERE BATES. THANK
YOU I'D LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF SENATOR
RUBIO REGARDING THE MANNER IN
WHICH IS COME FORWARD AND- THE
PROBLEM OF REALLY HAVING AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DIG INTO THE
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES BETWEEN OUR
SHIP IN THE MANUFACTURE OF
CURRENTLY THAT WOULD AS I WOULD
ASSUME IN IT'S JUST A QUESTION
PERHAPS A STATEMENT AND A
QUESTION NOT UNDERSTANDING OF
FLAT FEE FOR BOARD CHOSE TO
ELIMINATE IF COME CHEN ENGINE
AND GO ALL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
THEY WOULD BE KLAY. BE FACTURE
WHO COULD HAVE. THERE SHIPS
DOWN TO OF VEHICLES IN A VERY
SHORT TIME TO BE ABLE TO
COMPETE WITH CANOE. WHO ARE
HAVE THIS TOOL. YOU KNOW I IN
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE THERE ARE
INNOVATIVE AND I THINK IT'S
GREAT IDEA BUT I THINK WE'VE
SET UP A SITUATION. OF
COMPETING AND A LITTLE THING
TEND DEALERSHIPS. ARM THAT'S
THE PROBLEM IN TERMS OF
CONSUMERS WHO CAN AND IS THIS
GOING TO BE A CANOE CAR I GIVE
FOR BETTER QUESTIONS. WE ARE AM
WARNING AT YOU SUBSCRIBE
SOMETHING LIKE AND MY IN SHORT
TERM. STEVE FACTOR THEIR CAR IN
BUYING OR I MIGHT GET A
MEMBERSHIP WITH CANOE AND IT'S
A CANOE CAR IS THERE. FOR OVER
A CHEVY MALL. FIVE I THINK IT
IT'S FULL COMP NOW TO HOW THOSE
TWO THINGS OPERATE.
CONCURRENTLY AN ANTI AND- I
GUESS. PARTNERSHIP VANS
COMPARED TO THE WAY IT DOES NOW
AND I THINK IF WE HAD MORE TIME
IN OF THE STAKEHOLDER ARE
MEETING FETTY FASHION ALPHA
JUST SAID BY SENATOR- RUBIO
WE'D UNDERSTAND THE CONCEPT
BETTER AND PERHAPS IT WOUL BE
MORE RECEPTIVE. ON THE PART OF
OUR DEALERSHIPS IN OUR EXISTING
OUR MANUFACTURE DEALERSHIP
RELATIONSHIP. KIND OF A MULTI
PHASE STATEMENT IN QUESTION BUT
CLARITY ON THAT POINT IS I
THINK EXTREMELY IMPORTANT FOR
THOSE OF US. DECIDING HOW WE'RE
GOING TO VOTE BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY TO OUR- THE WAY WE
CURRENTLY UNDERSTAND THE
AUTOMOTIVE MANUFACTURING ON OUR
DEALERSHIP SALE A RELATIONSHIP
YEAH. YOU KNOW I'VE I THINK.
THROUGH THE CHAIR THE GOOD THE
GOOD SENATOR CAN APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT PART OF WHAT MAKES.
PROCESS DIFFICULT IS I TO A
GROUP OF FOLKS TO RUN THE
SYSTEM NOW AND THEY DON'T WANT
TO SEE ANY CHANGES IN THIS
AREA- AND SO I THINK THEY'RE.
THEY'RE GENERAL TAKE HIS BAND
WOULD LIKE JUST STOP THE BILL
RIGHT AS A TO ENGAGE. IN REAL
CALM OF HOW WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
MAKE MODEL WITH THIS SO THAT'S
BEEN A CHALLENGE I MEAN I GUESS
I THINK FROM RTG IN MY
PERSPECTIVE IT'S BEEN DIFFICULT
TO JUST TRY TO UNILATERALLY
IMPOSE A MODEL THAT WOULD
INCLUDE THEM WITHOUT INCLUDING
THEM IN THE DISCUSSION BUT IF
THEY WANT TO PURCHASE
DISCUSSION BECAUSE THE THEY
WANT. THAT ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
BUT FOR OUR FROM IN
PERSPECTIVES PART OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE IS FORCE THEM
TO THE TABLE SO WE CAN ACTUALLY
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW
TO INCLUDE THEM INTO THE INTO
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL- AND
I THAT'S IT THAT'S- I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT. I THINK
CAN INCREASE BECAUSE YOU'VE ALL
HAD DIFFICULT BILLS. BILLS THAT
IF YOU TRY TO CHANGE PARADIGMS
AND YOU NEED TO. FORCE PEOPLE
TO THE CONVERSATION AND THAT'S-
EFFECTIVELY WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE- WE ARE ABSOLUTELY OPEN.
TO TALKING ABOUT A MODEL WHERE
MY FORD. COULD SELL IT YOU
COULD COULD COULD HAVE
MEMBERSHIP. FIVE IDEALLY WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO SIT DOWN WITH
FORD AND WORKED OUT WITH THEM
WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE AND
HOW THEY WOULD FIT INTO THIS
MODEL. SO THAT'S MY HOPE THAT
WE'LL BE ABLE TO. YOU KNOW WITH
HIS BILL MOST FOR IT WILL BE
ABLE TO GET EVERYBODY AT TO THE
TABLE AND HAVE THEM TAKE THIS
CONVERSATION SERIOUSLY AND THEN
REALLY TALKED ABOUT HOW. TO
INCLUDE THEM. OKAY IN MY ON MY
OWN TIME I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THAT ANSWER SENATOR ALLEN AND
PERHAPS- THE ROOT PROBLEM HERE
IS A GOOD AN AMOUNT- WE PUT
PEOPLE WE'VE TAKEN WHAT IS A
TRADITIONAL- IN HOMERIC OF
BUSINESS MODEL NOW I GIVE
INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS MODEL
AND WE ARE ON. SURE PERIOD OF
TIME BUT THE MAN PLEASE OF
LEGISLATION WE'RE KIND OF UP IN
AND WE'RE SAYING YOU GUYS.
HERE'S WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO YOU
KNOW COME TO THE TABLE AND
YOU'VE GOT A MONTH AND BY THE
WAY WE'RE NOT MEETING FOR THREE
NIGHTS BECAUSE OF THE IT IS.
ETCETERA KIND OF AN UN.
CRITICISM THAT THEY HAVEN'T
COME TO THE TABLE. IF YOU WANT
TO THE TABLE- THERE OUGHT TO BE
A STUDY BILL ON HOW WE LOOK AT
THE BUSINESS MODEL. OF TRIM IT
FROM INFECTION HERE THROUGH THE
CANOE PROPOSAL. AND HALF THAT
WILL INDIAN. INCORPORATE THE
EXISTING MODEL AND GIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BOLSA. THOSE
FOLKS. ARE YOU'RE HEARING FROM
SENATOR BE THE LITTLE
RESISTANCE TO THE GOD AND-
PROCESS WE GO THROUGH UNLESS
THERE'S- A SIGNIFICANT.
IMMEDIATE. MERCHANT AND- SEE
THAT NEEDS THAT EXPOSE. IN BOB
DOUBLE I WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT I DON'T
WANT THAT TO BE TAKEN IF NOT
APPRECIATING THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT THE F. OUR MODEL PROVIDES
TO THE CONSUMERS AND CERTAINLY
ARE I'LL CALL GOAL FOR YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE. JUST ONE.
PLEASE OKAY SO THIS IS THIS IS
THIS. THE GOVERNMENT ISSUE IS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO OUR CURRENT
CRISIS I HAD PROPOSED THIS BILL
IT WAS IN FRAME AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR. THEN YOU
KNOW WE WERE ALL BEING TOLD ON
LEASE ON THE SENATE SIDE- TO
DRAMATICALLY. CUT BACK OUR BILL
LOAD AND I DECIDED TO ONE BACK.
ON YOU KNOW SO I AND I DID THAT
OUT OF RESPECT FOR THE PROCESS.
THEN OF COURSE IT SEEMED IT DID
THE AMEND SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WERE NOT BEING QUITE
AS- COPPER THAT PROCESS. AND
CERTAINLY NOT ON THE OTHER SIDE
AND WE WORK TOGETHER WITH THE
CHAIR AND WITH THE CARD. TO
LEAVE IT THIS THIS IDEA BACK ON
THE TABLE COULD I THINK IT HAS
AS WE DISCUSSED EARLIER I
REALLY WANT YOU KNOW WHETHER WE
ALL WANT TO FORCE THIS
DISCUSSION SO WHY THIS. THIS
PARTICULAR VEHICLE THE GOTTEN
AND IT IS NOT AS THOUGH. SHE
WAS IN PRINT FOR THE FIRST
TIME. IN THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS
THIS ISSUE HAS BEEN IN PRINT
THROUGH THE FORM OF MY BILL
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING OF THE
YEAR. I KNOW OF IT IS
COMPLICATED EVERYTHING IT'S
COMPLICATED THIS BILLS PROCESS
THAT'S ALL VALID. AND CERTAIN
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT AS
WELL BUT I DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO
BELIEVE THAT THIS. YEAH I'M
GONNA. GET A LOT. THE CASE
THANK YOU YEAH THE COUPLING
GALGIANI SENATOR HE SENATOR
BELL- I APPRECIATE THE INTENT
OF THE AUTHOR AND I DID MEET
WITH THE NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION THIS BILL AND I OUT
THERE THEY HAD SUGGESTED SOME
AMENDMENTS AND I WAS TOLD THAT.
BECAUSE IT'S A NEW BIT MODEST
SQUARE SERVICE AT THAT AGE
DON'T ASK WHAT IS WORKABLE AND
PROVIDE THOSE TALES FOR A
SERVICE BUT ALL THAT SENATE
INFANCY IS DIFFICULT AT THIS
POINT AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
ABILITY TO- AND- HE- VEHICLE. I
HAVE SOME WHERE WE PRESCRIBE IN
STATUTE EXACTLY HOW THE
BUSINESS MODEL SHOULD RUN AND
WHO THE WINNERS ARE AND WHO THE
LOSERS ARE AND THAT'S THAT AND
THAT I HAVE WITH THIS BILL IF
THERE WAS A BEHAVIOR OR
ACTIVITY THAT WAS HEARD CONSUME.
AT A DIFFERENT SO PERHAPS IT
WAS. WAS THERE SOMETHING THAT
OCCURRED THAT. ROB DID THIS
THAT NEEDS A LEGISLATIVE REMEDY.
GENERAL YET TO THE CHAIR AND
RUSSIAN THE EFFECTIVELY YES AND
I CAN TALK TO YOU MORE ABOUT
THE DETAILS BAIT BAIT THERE HAS
BEEN A CONCERTED EFFORTS TO
PREVENT INNOVATION IN THIS
SPACE AND I THINK WERE. I THINK
THE SPONSORS AND- OUR A AND THE
SUPPORTERS THE BILL ARE HOPING.
TO PROVOKE. A MORE ROBUST
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS MODEL.
BECAUSE THERE THERE THERE ARE
YOU KNOW THE SAME FOLKS ARE
OPPOSING THIS BILL HAVE HAVE OF
FINDING STE- IN COURT ELSEWHERE.
THE EFFORTS FOR SOME OF THE
FOLKS WHO WANT TO CREATE THIS
MODEL AND GET THIS MODEL OUT
THERE TO PROVIDE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONSUMERS.
FROM FROM BEING ABLE TO DO THAT.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS
BILL WOULD ESSENTIALLY PROHIBIT
THE OTHER CAR DEALERS SOLUTION
THE CARD DEALERS FROM HAVING
THEIR CURRENT SUBSCRIPTION
MODELS THAT IT ACTUALLY NOT
THREE THIS IS THIS CREATES A
NEW LOW. REMEMBER THE MODEL.
THAT THEY CAN PROCEED WITH THIS
DOESN'T IT THIS DOESN'T PREVENT
THEM FROM THE ALL TO DO WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO UNDER THE
CURRENT. UNDER CURRENT WORK. SO
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE THEIR
SUBSCRIPTION MODELS THAT THEY
HAVE CURRENTLY IN PRACTICE
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING OF YOU
BEEN GIVING UP IS THERE
SOMETHING THAT. THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING I CERTAINLY IF
YOU IF YOU THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING THE NEED TO BRING MY
ATTENTION TO IT I'M NOT SURE OF
I'M I'M- YOU KNOW POLICY WILL
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT FOR THAT.
THAT'S NOT OUR INTENT. OKAY SIR
BRIAN. THANK YOU THE CARE I GOT
A QUESTION THE AUTHOR THE FLOOR
JOCKEY. SO TO I LOOK IN MY
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION I SEE
TESLA NOT IN IT THEY ONLY WANT
ALLEGE THEY ONLY MAKE. VEHICLES
ARE THEY AT THIS TIME WITH THE
AND I KNOW THAT THEIR A DEALER-
ARE THEY ABLE TO. USE THIS.
TECHNOLOGY OR THIS LEGISLATION-
AND IF SO- WHY WOULDN'T THE
PEOPLE OF CANOE CHIPS. GET OF A
LICENSE LIKE THEY HAVE AND MOVE
FORWARD YEAH. ADD TO CHAIRED BY
THE WAY I GOT CLEARLY FROM THE
STATUS NOW ON. SENATE GALGIANI
THAT DID ABSOLUTELY THIS THE
CURRENTS OF SENATE GALGIANI THE
ON THE SUBSCRIPTION PROGRAM
THAT ARE. THAT THE OTHER FOLKS
ARE ARE TAKING ARE DOING I
WOULD NOT BE IMPACTED BY THIS
BILL SO THEY COULD. WE CAN TO
PROGRAM IS IT BECAUSE EXISTING
PROGRAM. CANCER CENTER DOLLAR
SAN. AND IT'S UNDER THAT. THAT
RIGHT NOW. THE TEST LIKE THE
BILL. THE WITH PROBLEM IS THAT
THE DO. WITHOUT THIS BILL THEY-
SAID THEY WANTED PURSUE THE-
THE MEMBERSHIP MODEL THAT'S
OUTLINED IN THE BILL. HAD
SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAS TO BE
PASSED. THANK IS THAT. OKAY
THANK YOU. SIR OUR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSER HERE NO SPEAK
OTHER ICE- SIR WHAT CAO SPEAKS
USING CENTER WHITE HOUSE CAN
ALL MOVE THE BILL. CAPTION ON
THE BILL CENTER I WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE I LOOK I
WANNA THINK MY COLLEAGUES AND I
WANT TO THINK. OF ALL THIS
DISCUSSION FOR THIS ROBUST
DEBATE I THINK YOU'VE ALL
BROUGHT A- SINGLE ONE OF YOU.
PRODUCT CRITICAL ISSUES. WE'LL
FIND A COUPLE THINGS THAT WERE
ONE OR TWO COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE BY THE FOLKS IN OPPOSITION.
WITH RESPECT ON THE ISSUE OF
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS. AS A
RESULT AND THANKS TO THE HELP
OF OUR FRIENDS FROM THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS THIS BILL
HAS TO THE STRONGEST CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS IN THE BUSINESS NOW
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THEY WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT BILL IN. THEY
INVOLVED IN IT SINCE AND AS A
RESULT WE'VE NOW ACCEPTED A
RAFT OF CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH HIS
BILL THAT REALLY MAKE IT A
STANDARD CARDS CONSUMER ACTION.
I TO THEM IN THEIR- MOUNTAINS.
I'M THERE IS A REAL IN ON THE
PART AYE AYE AYE KNOW THAT I
EMPHASIZE IT ENOUGH A REAL
INTEREST ON THE PART OF MYSELF
AND I KNOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER CG
TO ENGAGE THE OPPOSITION AND TO
TRY TO THINK ABOUT HOW THE
THIS. I THINK THE DATE GOT.
HIGH QUALITY ELECTRIC VEHICLES
THAT WE WANT TO GET OUT THERE.
WE WANT IN THE PART OF THE
SOLUTION AS WELL. YOU KNOW THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS IT OLD
MODEL. OF CAR OWNERSHIP WORKS
MANY OF US- BUT DOESN'T WORK.
EVERYBODY AND CERTAINLY DOESN'T
WORK A LOT OF YOUNGER PEOPLE OR
PEOPLE WHO ARE STRUGGLING
ECONOMICALLY. THIS IS A NEW
WAY. TO GET MORE. EVEN OUT.
PEOPLE'S I AM. IN GET BEHIND
WE'LL GET THEM TRYING THESE
DOUBT BUT IT THE WAY THAT FROM
THEM WITH MORE FOR. THEY DON'T
TO TAKE ON ALL OF THE ALL OF
THE RISK OF ALL OF CALLS FOR IN
A- WITH A TRUE. I BUT IT REALLY
DOES COME THEIR CAR LIKE I SAID.
MY WITH THEIR LIVING AROUND
CARS AND SHARING THEM. SO THEY
CAN ACTUALLY FEEL THAT THEY
THEY HAVE THE CONFIDENCE TO
KNOW THAT THIS IS A CAR THAT IS
TAKEN OUT OF THE DEALERSHIP
THAT. ON THE DAY. HAVE HAVE
HAVE. HELLO SO THIS IS A NEW
MODEL THE NO ABOUT THAT ON A NO
I JUST THROW OUT THERE ARE
INTERESTING TO INCLUDE. DEALERS
IN THE CAR TAX IS THAT. HOW WE
COME UP MODEL TOGETHER THAT
WILL WORK FOR THEM TO WORK FOR
THE SPONSORS- AND SO I ASK YOU
TO. CONTINUE THAT DISCUSSION I
AND YOU KNOW THIS. COULD VERY
WELL LIKELY OFF INTO THE FUTURE
INCLUDING INTO NEXT YEAR YOU
KNOW ANYTHING THAT IS IN THIS
BILL THAT DOESN'T WORK FOR THE
FOLKS INVOLVED I CAN BE CHANGED
AS SKINNER SAID A VERY WELL
UNIT BUT THIS THIS IS A WORK
QUESTION. DOES FOR THE
NEGOTIATE AND FURTHER DISCUSS.
THE FOLKS WILL PUT THIS TODAY.
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER WHERE CAL SKI
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS.
UP CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AND AS A REMINDER PLEASE
SPEAK CLEARLY INTO THE
MICROPHONE SO THAT EVERYBODY
CAN HEAR YOU. SENATE BILL HI
BILL HI SENATE DEBATES NO BATES
NO. ALLEN HI HISENATOR
DOLLINGER GO BELLY NOW SENATOR
DODD HI- HI SENATOR GALGIANI
NOW GO JOHNNY NO CENTER
GONZALEZ I THE BILL OF.
THURMOND LIVE. THERMAL AND AS.
SENDER MORALE EL AL NO. SENATOR
OFF OUR ROTH HI CENTER RUBIO
NOW VOTING. RUBIO NOT VOTING.
SENATOR SKINNER. SENATOR
SKINNER HI DINNER HI. THIRD
NUMBER. CENTER Y. CASKEY HI I
KELSEY I. SEVENTY FOUR MISTER
CHAIRMAN. WHAT WAS THE VOTE
PLEASE SEVEN TO FOUR THE VOTE
WAS SEVEN IN FAVOR FOR OPPOSED
AND WE WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL BECAUSE WE HAVE THREE
MEMBERS NOTPRESENT A TIME SO
LEAVE IT ON CALL TO THE END OF
THE MEETING. NOW THE MATING
MEASURE ARE ON A CONSENT
COUNTER WE HAD TO CAN. THERE IS
THE FIRST THE WILL BE ON THE-
THEY'RE ON CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND THE BILLS ON CONSENT CALAR
CONSIST OF ITEM NUMBER TWO A.
B. TWO THIRTY EIGHT ITEM FOR A.
B. FORO EIGHT. ITEM FIVE A. B.
TWO ZERO ZERO SIX. ITEM SIX A.
B. TWO ZERO THREE EIGHT ITEM
SEVEN A. B. TWO ONE FOUR ONE.
ITEM EIGHT A. B. TWO ONE SEVEN
TWO. ITEM NUMBER NINE IS A. B.
TWO TWO EIGHT FIVE ITEM TEN IS
A. B. TWO SIX SIX THREE. AN
ITEM ELEVEN IS A. B. THREE TWO
SEVEN SEVEN. IS THERE A MOTION
ON THIS FIRST CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
DODD. IT CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR BILL HI WELL
HI SURVEYS HI HI. SENATOR ALLEN
HI ELLEN HI SENATOR DOLLY HI
DOLLY HI SENATOR DODD. HEY
DONNA HI CENTER GALGIANI AYE
GALGIANI AYE THAT OUR GONZALEZ
FIVE DOLLARS HI SENATOR MCGUIRE.
HI I WOULD USE IT IN THE MIKE
CENTER PLEASE AT THE CHOIR I
THANK YOU HI IN A MOMENT. SEND
A MORALE- ALLIED REAL HIGH THEN
ROTH IRA BROUGHT. COULD RUBIO
HI THE BILL HI YOURSELF SENATOR
SKINNER. SENATOR SKINNER HI.
NUMBER IT'S A MESS SENATOR LIKE
HEALTHY HI KELSEA. THIRTEEN TO
ZERO WE HAVE THIRTEEN IN FAVOR
ZERO OPPOSED AND WE HAD TO
ABSENT MEMBERS LEAD ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT THE ABSENT MEMBERS
RETURN THE TIME THE MEETING IS
OVER OKAY NOW LET'S CALL THE
ROLL THIS CONSENT WHICH
INCLUDES THE RESOLUTIONS. SCOTT
THIS ITEM NUMBER ONE S. C. R.
EIGHTY NINE. OF ITEM TWELVE ACR.
NINETY SEVEN. ITEM THIRTEEN IS
A C. R. ONE OH SEVEN. ITEM
FOURTEEN IS A C. R. ONE ONE TWO
ITEM FIFTEEN IS A C. R. ONE ONE
NINE ITEM SIXTEEN IS ACR. ONE
TWO ZERO ITEM SEVENTEEN IS A C.
R. ONE TWO FOUR. ITEM EIGHTEEN
IS ACE OR ONE TWO SEVEN ITEM
NINETEEN IS ACR ONE TWO EIGHT
ITEM TWENTY IS A C. R. ONE
THREE NINE. ITEM TWENTY ONE IS
A C. R. ONE FOUR SEVEN AND ITEM
TOO MANY TO IS A C. R. ONE SIX
I THINK I WAS RIGHT. IS THERE A
MOTION FOR THE SECOND CONSENT.
WE HAVE A MOTION PLEASE SIR WHY
KOWSKI MAKES A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR NUMBER
TWO. SENATOR BILL BILL HI
SENATE DEBATE HI PAGE LINE
CENTER ALLEN HI ELLEN HI
SENATOR DOLLINGER. HI SENATOR
DODD. SENATOR GALGIANI AYE
GALGIANI AYE SENATOR GONZALEZ I
CAN SALAS HI SENATE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE HI SENATOR
MELINDA. SENATOR MORALE HI WELL
HI SENATOR ROTH HI RALPH HI
SENATOR RUBIO HI RUBIO BY
SENATOR SKINNER. SENATOR
SKINNER YEAH NO. SENATOR UMBERG.
CENTER LIKE HEALTHY I LIKE
KELSEY I. ELEVEN ONE WE HAVE
ELEVEN VOTES IN FAVOR OPPOSE-
WILL OPEN THAT ROLE OPEN FOR I
HAVE SENT MEMBERS. AND THAT'S
ALL THE BILLS. AND. WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS- FOR THE MISSING
CENTERS RETURN A LOT OF WOMEN
OTHER COMMITTEES ALL OF GIVE
THEM A CHANCE TO COME BACK TO
CAST THEIR VOTES HOWEVER WE
HAVE CENTER WIRE HERE OPEN THE
ROLE. AND OPEN THE ROLE ON. THE.
AB THREE TO SIX CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. CALL THE ROLL PLEASE AB
THREE TO SIX EIGHTY THREE TO
SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATE RIGHT BLAIR HIGH CENTER
MELENDEZ. FEDERAL BURKE OKAY
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. OF WE CAN
WE CALL THE ROLL ON THE SECOND
CONSENT CALENDAR. PLEASE. ON
THE SECOND CONSENT CALENDAR-
SENATOR DODD. DODD HI CENTER
MELENDEZ CENTER NUMBER. THANK
YOU. WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN
FOR THE TWO ABSENT MEMBERS.
WHICH I HOPE WILL BE HERE SOON.
WE WILL WAIT TO LEAVE THE ROLE
FOR THE ASENT MEMBERS TO
RETURN FROM. OTHER BUSINESS
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBER
COMMITTEES ARE HAVING HEARINGS
NOW SO. SENATORS ARE IN THOSE
AREAS AND THEN WE'LL ADJOURN.
SO CENTER RUBIO CAN SHARE HER
COMMITTEE WHICH IS A COMING UP
AFTER MINE. SO OKAY. SO WE WANT
TO CENTERS TO RETURN VOTE SO WE
CAN. CLEAR THE CHAMBERS CLEAN
THE CHAMBERS AND START THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE.
OKAY WE'RE
GOING RECORD VOTE SCHOOL CALL
THE ROLL ON A. B. THREE TO SIX
PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS TH
AND MELENDEZ. CENTER ON BURKE
NUMBER GUY. OKAY THANK YOU WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS CAN WE GO ON TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE.
SENATOR ON BUT CAN YOU VOTE ON
THE CONSENT COUNTERS. A CONSENT
CALENDAR NUMBER ONE SENATE
MELENDEZ. THE NUMBER NUMBER GUY.
CONSENT CALENDAR NUMBER TWO.
SENATE MELENDEZ CENTER ON BURKE
NUMBER GUY THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU. OKAY THE FINAL VOTE.
ON AB. THREE TO SIX. NINE. THAT
WAS FIVE. BY DOUBLES. SO
REGRETTABLE BUT NOT OKAY THE
FINAL VOTE ON AB THREE TO SIX
IS NINE IN FAVOR FOR OPPOSED
ONE NOT VOTING ONE ONE NINE
HERE AND ONE APPS AND THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- THE FINAL
VOTE IS FOURTEEN TO ZERO ON
NUMBER ONE AND- IT IS. THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN TO ONE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR NUMBER TWO. OKAY.
THANK YOU EVERYBODY. I THANK
ALL THE VISUALS TO TESTIFIED
TODAY AND- PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS IN WRITING- TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE WE WANT TO
INCLUDE THEM IN THE TESTIMONY
POCKET IF YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. FOR
OFFICIAL RECORDS THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
PATIENT IN COOPERATION WITH THE
SENATE- TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE WE ARE ADJOURNED